only a few flights to Turks and Caicos a
day right because it's a really small
airport I booked on separate Airlines
Turks and Caicos is in the Caribbean
right yeah yeah yeah but that means you
have to recheck and go back through
security yeah and they lost Kelsey's bag
JetBlue lost it and they're like oh
we'll just you know we'll put it on your
next flight and we're like well we're on
a separate Airline and they're like oh
well we'll just give it to the airline
and you just have to have to hope that
they're gonna send it it's our honeymoon
right it's day one I got all my bags I'm
chilling so sorry sorry I'm in my I'm in
my swim trunks I'm in the ocean like
babe you gotta get in here it's amazing
she's in a full sweatsuit one of the
ladies that works at the hotel was just
super nice and she was like I have a
friend who works at the airport she hit
him up and he just went back there and
just was able to find the bag and put it
on a car and they drove it to the hotel
wow